hello uh welcome to my talk thank you
very much for coming um and uh i'd like
to
thank the organizers for allowing me to
speak here it was
a very much a last minute affair for me
i saw a post on linkedin by cherry
saying oh there's one day left before
the deadline
um
so a bit of a mad scramble to
put a proposal in
and i'm glad to say that i put together
something which i think is pretty
relevant for
pie data um
although you know a few years ago i
might have thought that perhaps this
wasn't something i knew anything near
enough about
um so
a little bit about me
first
um so i'm a research software engineer
on the data sig project which is a joint
project between
the university of oxford ucl imperial
and the alan turing institute
and basically our our mission
uh if you call it that is to
bring signature methods and rough path
theory to
people in the data science community and
people doing time series analysis
anything that involves perhaps and and
we'll see in a little while that my
definition of path might be um
not necessarily things that you expect
so i uh i call myself a python
enthusiast
i i started programming python when i
was a phd student um
a long time ago
uh but i'm a pure mathematician at heart
i did a phd in pure mathematics i
lectured pure mathematics for for a
short while um and then
somehow i ended up
teaching python and as part of that i
went to pycon uk and i found out about
these wonderful jobs called research
software engineers uh highly recommend
uh to anybody who's who might be so
inclined it's very good fun it's like
the uh the perfect matchup between my
nerdy maps side and my nerdy programming
side it's the perfect storm um i also
wrote a book
uh which was also something i wasn't
expecting to do um i'm not going to talk
about it but it's called applying math
in python um
the the math bit really still bothers me
today i'm i'm british so
maths is the correct pronunciation
um
but uh we won't go into that anymore
and as i said i was formally lecturing
pure mathematics or mathematics in
general um
a couple of universities for for a while
and i thought this was a really nice
place to start because in a really
really roundabout kind of strange way
this
is really the start of my story when it
comes to analyzing time series
so
back in 2017
i know the pre-times
i was lecturing at nottingham trent
university in a sort of
gap period where i was weren't sure what
i was going to do
and i was asked to supervise some third
year dissertation students and
one of them was a very good student
who was a financial math student
actually not a not a pure mathematician
um but because of the the reasons i was
i was in this job they'd asked me to
carry on with
supervising
uh so i said yes no problem i'll do that
and uh
after a little bit of discussion after a
meeting or two we decided that uh well
she she decided that uh she'd like to
understand how
events in the world um have an effect on
stocks on
prices on
anything
in general so
this was all about how you take
some kind of information about the world
and predict what might happen
in stock market or any anywhere else
and this was really interesting
unfortunately being a pure mathematician
i know absolutely nothing about stock
option pricing or
how to actually deal with these things
i'd done a little bit of statistics
dealing with
time series data when i was a bachelor
student
many years prior
um oops
sorry snapcraft being a bit disagreeable
there
but i really didn't know anything
anywhere near enough to
really do this student justice and i'm
i'm not saying that this student didn't
do well she did very very well
um
what she produced was
very very good and reflective of the
work that she put in but from my side i
felt that i let the student down because
i could have
i could have given her way more
information about this if i'd known then
what i know now
so this is an exercise in hindsight um
really
so what is it that i
i should have known then that i know now
and the answer to that question is
control differential equations
so
broadly speaking a controlled
differential equation is something where
you take in some kind of
information about the world a path
that describes some events that are
happening in the world and you try to
predict the response to that
input path that control
so here my input signal is x
x t it's a path it's something that
depends on some time parameter or
actually it doesn't have to be time
parameter
but it informs some kind of
variability in a system and from that i
generate an output signal my y of t
and usually has some
formal relationship um defined by this
equation so what this is saying is that
the
small increments of y depend on some
function of y
and
the small increments of x
and that sounds
horribly complicated and
it is and i don't claim to understand
this theory at all but luckily
my supervisor oxford terry lyons
literally invented this field of
mathematics so he knows a lot about it
unfortunately i can just implement the
things he he
sends my way and this is
a very good relationship i think
so it turns out that the result
the solution of this kind of
differential equation ends up being
determined by an important
construction
which depends on the input path x and
that is called the signature of the path
and really what this is is an abstract
summary of the variability of the path
that you take in
i'm not going to go into any more detail
about controlled differential equations
so you can breathe a sigh of relief
this is a very deep and very
mathematical topic
i don't need to go anywhere near as deep
into that
but i am going to go into
signatures because signatures are
definitely more interesting to this
crowd
so what is a signature well i said
before signature is an abstract
description of the
uh of a path
um and it lives in this horrible scary
space here the tensor algebra
um
but what this is saying really is i have
some information at lots of different
levels okay so my levels are the case
here and
each level describes an extra dimension
of the variability of the path okay
and we'll see later that actually
usually you you truncate this because
obviously
you we can't deal with infinity in
computers that does not work
um but for now let's just
pretend that this is what we have
and what we really do is we flatten all
this out into one big long line so the
the number in the top uh there inside
the brackets that is the level k
and
this is indexed by
words so tensor words um in a let a
d-dimensional alphabet okay so i have my
first element is the zeroth element
that's just a scalar
so a real number
um and then i have d letters
uh one through d
rather unimaginatively because we're
mathematicians we don't like to
complicate things if we don't have to
and now they're my level one elements
and then i have the level two elements
which are things like one one one two
one d and then all the way up to dd
and i write them out in this lexus
graphical order
and i get this long sequence and then
finally somewhere in the in the ether i
have the nth level which has
letters i want i up to i n as my word
um and
this is this is an abstract abstract
description of the path
um
oh well it will be there are more tenses
of this form than there are descriptions
of paths we'll see that in a minute
so
the signature of a path actually has a
very special form inside this i'm not
going to go into exactly the details of
this but there there's there is so a
small subset of all these possible long
sequences that are actually signatures
of paths
and
i can write down exactly what the
elements are
by sort of enumerating these words
um
and and writing out full
so the the first term the scalar term is
always one
okay
and you'll see why this is relevant in a
moment but
basically solutions to differential
equations going back to that for briefly
usually look like exponentials
one is usually at the beginning of an
exponential in some way
so next i have
differences or increments
in my
values of each letter okay so these are
are the differences in the ith
coordinate
uh between the end point and the start
point so my my i'm looking over this
interval a to b
and this is just the increment that
occurs in the x
in the i-coordinates of x
over this interval
so i have d of those
and then my second terms are
double integrals
where i'm integrating over the sort of
triangle that's defined between two
coordinates in my path so i'm
integrating the i-coordinate of my path
against the j-th coordinate of my path
over the sort of triangle
defined between them
this is
this is a scary looking quantity but
it's something that we can actually
compute okay and we don't have to do any
complicated integrals uh to actually
compute these in real world scenarios
and i'll come back to that in a few
moments
and then we
go down through all of the different
levels and we end up with this horrible
iterated integral
somewhere down off in the in the world
but uh the exact formulation of this
doesn't actually matter so much because
computationally
there's a very convenient way of writing
these things out
okay so as i said here uh just this is
more for the people reading the slides
later
x i t is the i coordinates of x t at
time t
okay so uh just to
very briefly summarize the properties of
such things um so
we're mathematicians we like to prove
theorems um so these are all sort of
little theorems about paths
and most of them come from the form of
the
integrals that we've just looked at
you don't need to know anything about
integration i'm about to tell you
everything that you need to know
for this to work but if you do
understand then great
okay so they're invariant to
reparameterization
uh so what does this mean it means that
if i take some transformation of my time
t
up up to some reasonable transformation
it's not going to change the values of
my integrals so the signature isn't
going to change either
it's translation invariant so if i shift
the whole path up
in the space then that's not going to
change anything if i shift it down shift
it around it's not going to change
anything
it respects concatenation and so if i
take my path and i split it in two
and i calculate the signatures of each
part of my path
and then i take their tensor product
then i get back the signature of the
whole path
this is important
this is the property which means that if
i look back at my controlled
differential equation this is the thing
that you need
for in order to solve that
using signatures
and as i said before
the the full signature is this infinite
object
and um this isn't practical for
computation so what we usually do is we
truncate it at some level
um so i write this as a s
with a superscript n and
the
the coordinates of the subscripts there
indicate the interval over which i
uh i'm computing
okay great um
what on earth have i just been talking
about um this is
abstract nonsense at its finest uh we're
we're deep down alice's rabbit hole
right so
if i look at these things and i i try
and describe
what the actual implement the actual uh
explanation of what all this is you
might recall that integrals give you
areas areas under curves
iterated integrals give you
areas
between two curves
in the appropriate domain
so if i look at the
one two element of uh of my signature
you'll notice that this is the iterated
integral over
the two coordinates of my path
i and j
or the one one and two and what this
really amounts to is actually the area
above
one part um
but
below it in the other sense or
between
this is really confusing because the the
the components are sort of living in
two-dimensional space but your area is
sort of being measured in in a third
sort of plane between them
okay so
the yellow highlighted area is sort of
like this integral the value of this
integral
and
similarly if i go to 2 1 it's the
corresponding bit the bit below
on this pet on this plane notice that my
my axes here are the first coordinate
and the second coordinate
so first coordinate on the x-axis second
on the y-axis so this is the
plane that sort of is between these two
coordinates
so these are these are the sort of
geometrical interpretations of the
values of these second degree elements
from the signature
and we can go further than this um
ignore this bottom things i i may have
borrowed this slide from uh from a
colleague who i think lots of people on
my team have borrowed these slides
because i got them from somebody else
not the original author but credit to
the original author
we can do
a little bit more with this so we can
do some differencing here and we end up
with these
bits between the curve and this diagonal
line that goes between the end points of
this curve and these are actually quite
important things
these are called levy areas
and
they are a very
interesting feature because they take
account of the order in which things
happen
um
i'm not going to go
too much into detail but basically
signatures
only really matter
uh sorry the the values of signatures
only really depend on the order in which
events happen and this goes back to what
i was talking about beginning when my
student wanted to look at the effect
of something
uh some event on market values
the order matters if the event happens
before some some reaction in the market
then it's
it's plausible that that event caused
that reaction if it happened after
then clearly it didn't have anything to
do with it although they may have had a
common cause in
in retrospect
so these levee areas are very important
and actually you can reduce the
complexity of your signature if you sort
of strip out the redundancy because
clearly these
the area above and the area below
you can kind of calculate from one
another
these levy areas are sort of like what
happens if you strip out all that
redundancy
i'm not going to talk about that today
notice that all of these are the
property of the path
and not of the points on which you
sample your path
they only depend on the path that they
came from
so
here's a really silly way to calculate
things
suppose that i
am given a sequence of increments
okay so these are the changes in my path
over some small
small
time interval
then i can actually calculate the higher
order terms from these
making some assumptions about what my
path might look like
and then i can use these increments to
calculate the whole signature or
something which approximates the whole
signature
so what i do
is i take
these increments and i embed them in my
tensor space
so the zero coordinate here is a
constant term that doesn't play any part
the
first order terms are replaced by my
increments and i set everything else to
zero
and then what i do is i take this
horrible product of the exponentials
of all of these increments and these are
exponentials in the free tensor algebra
so they're defined as this formal power
series where you take 1 plus x plus x
squared over 2 plus
so on and so forth if you're if you're
familiar with how the exponential
function is defined as a power series
then it's the same form it's just that
every time you're doing a tensor product
instead of a
or a tensor power instead of a normal
multiplication
this is a well-defined object
and it gives you
something which approximates the
signature terms of higher order
using only this first order increment
data
okay um
so i realized that was a lot
um so here's a really really silly
little example
so suppose i've been given two
increments
say x one is one two and x two is three
four um who's who's done an example of
of something where they've used these
these two points for for
show of hands anyone yeah
it's a common thing i love it i've got
dozens of examples of matrix algebra
with one two three four and a square
matrix
so for example these could have come
from a path that i'd sampled
with the point 0 0 1 2 and 4 6 okay so
if i take the difference between
consecutive things i get these two
increments
so what i do is i embed them in my
tensor algebra and i take their
exponential okay i'm just going up to
level two here um so this is the
constant term the increments and then
this
increment tensor product increment
divided by two
okay so um these are
fairly easy to uh to work out if you if
you take tens of product or two vectors
it's the outer product so you you take
the first coordinate of one times the
first coordinate the other and that
gives you the top left
if you take out these four
uh last elements this is like a two by
two matrix you get if you
put the the vectors the wrong way around
in the dot product right
it gives you a two by two matrix
and this is the outer product of these
two
and i do this for both increments and i
get two values
and then i take the tensor product of
these two things okay so i've written
out in full here so you can see exactly
what the form of this is so the first
term is always one
that's fine i can do that
then i've got my
increment values
okay so in the tensor product these are
really added together because
it's like one times this plus one times
the other
and then the higher order terms are all
slightly more complicated but not much
basically there's one contribution
coming from the increments and one
contribution coming from each of the
other um
sorry there's one one contribution
coming from each of the level two
things on either side and then one
contribution coming from the two level
one
uh terms in the middle
so if you chase this through you'll see
where old terms come from
there's tens of product
okay so that was the signature a very
stupid example um
why is this interesting
well
there's a theorem
that tells me that if i look at paths
up to some equivalents
there's the magic words
then
all of the functions that i can describe
on paths or the continuous functions
are exactly
linear functions defined on signatures
in other words anything i can learn
about the behavior of a path
i can learn from the signature
and vice versa
so
if i know something about signature i
know something about the path
that might be interesting
in particular
if i take path data so i sample data
from a path
and i compute its signature
i can make inference based on the
signature and not the original path data
and here's the crunch
the
dimensionality of path data can be
enormous if i take a path and i sample
it a million times
then i've got a million times the
dimension of my path
but my signature over that if i compute
the signature of all those million
points
up to some degree
my signature has only as many points as
it would have if i had one point the
signature
is a fixed size object
so it's
it's exponential and sorry it's
geometric in the powers of
of the thing so
if i have two coordinates then the
signature of level d has two to the n
plus one minus one o
uh points in it
okay so it's uh it's like one plus d
plus d squared plus d cubed et cetera
this is fixed
so
the number of
terms in my signature does not depend at
all on how many increments i use to
calculate it but it still summarizes the
variability that's captured in those
increments
now this is hugely important for anybody
who's tried to
put
time series into some kind of machine
learning or data sciencey kind of
algorithm where if you try and put a
million points in
something is going to break or it's
going to take a really long time
but even a modest depth signature
could have you know
a few thousand points
tens of thousands of points that's still
a lot less than a million
so
this can be used as a way to reduce the
size and complexity of a data set that
you then feed in to a machine learning
model say
all right so can i give you a real
example and the answer is yes
so let's take two paps
here so i'm going to take some paps
which are handwritten
digits and i believe these are taken
from the mnist dataset if anyone's
familiar with that
so these are perhaps and i've flipped
the axes um a little bit
so that they're drawn the correct way
around on using matplotlib so
the points are sort of uh sampled points
taken from a person drawing on a on a
graphics tablet of some description and
these are the digits the paths that they
describe
these don't look like traditional time
series
but really they are because these are
sampled over a small amount of time as
someone draws these characters
i would love to have given you a live
demonstration of this but i don't have
the software to or a graphics tablet to
to do this and the pad on my laptop
probably isn't up to it
so i i get these these two continuous
paths that i can
interrogate using signatures and try and
understand how they are constructed
so
um
i need to compute signatures obviously
i'm not going to do this by hand um
i'm a mathematician and i think the
uh the quality of a mathematician is
that you've done at least one
computation by hand that you regret
doing
that's what mathematica is for or maple
or whatever symbolic maths package you
have
um
so what this really is is a reasonably
short sequence of
values or increments in a
two-dimensional space okay so these are
not complicated objects but i don't want
to compute them by hand
so let's try and identify the digit
three using a signature
and um
not
capturing anything so i'm obviously not
going to do this with just one i'm going
to take a few of them and
combine them in some way to get
something that i can use to then
classify
and um just
just
a little uh
note this is the least scientific way
that i could possibly imagine to do this
problem with but it it's basic and it
shows the point without going too much
into detail
okay so
what my procedure is going to be i'm
going to take
several digit threes from this data set
that i have i'm going to compute their
signatures
then i'm going to
compute the expected signature so this
is just the average the mean signature
over my different things so i'm going to
get a
thing that looks like the signature of a
three uh or summarizes in some way the
signature of three and i'm going to
compare new path signatures
of new digits that i've not seen before
and see if they're also similar to
threes
okay so there are actually several
python packages for computing signatures
so there's e-cig
ii signature and signatory
signatory is based on pi torch so if
you're
into using pytorch as a machine learning
framework then you can plug this
straight in
and i'll show you some example code well
i'll tell you where to find some example
code in a moment because i don't like
putting code on my slides
um i'm the maintainer of e-cig
and
while it's not quite in the form that
i'm terribly happy with at the moment um
there are major updates coming
so i'm going to use e-cig to do these
computations mostly because it's the
only one i had installed
so there's a function in ecig called
stream to sig which takes a stream of
points and computes compute signature
and it just takes it this is like an n
dimensional or an n times d array so n
is the number of samples d is the number
of dimensions of my path
and it does the differencing for you so
you don't have to convert these to
increments
okay so i'm going to take um
depth eight so this level eight
signatures
um so these are gonna have two to the
nine minus one points in them or in
other words 511
entries
and this is going to be my my feature
space if you like
so let's actually calculate these things
so
if i compute this all these signatures
and i take their average
this is roughly what i get or at least
this is the first few terms of what i
get okay so you can see the one at the
front there
minus 0.04 1.88 and so on so these are
this is an abstract summary of what i
expect a three to look like
so what happens if i take a new path
and i compute its signature
okay well this is what i get when i do
such a thing
and you'll notice that it's not terribly
dissimilar but there is some definite
differences particularly in these these
higher order terms here so i've got
really small
middle second order terms no 0.84 0.89
these don't look quite the same
and if i compute their
naively their maximum modulus distance
um is 5.27 which is pretty large i mean
considering the size of these
coordinates that i've put up this is
quite a big difference
and in fact
they are different
um this is the signature of the six path
i showed you on the first slide
so
i
if i'd guessed that these were not the
same based on this data
i would have been correct now i'm not
saying that this is a good way to
classify digits um there are far better
ways of doing this
but
this is a very stupid way of doing it
which sort of works and it shows you
roughly what kind of things are possible
so what kinds of things are possible
well obviously there's handwriting
recognition and um we've done quite well
with this actually by analyzing the
strokes uh and drawing a path
um
this is something that we have a good
example of on our on our website and
details in a moment
um so this is from the mnist data set um
which as i said i think these digits
were actually taken from this set as
well
then we have sepsis detection so
we
used pap signatures
to predict sepsis in the mimic three
data set which has been mentioned at
least one over time this this weekend
um
this uh i believe was part of a kaggle
or similar kind of competition and i
believe we did pretty well
then there's human action recognition
using landmark data so we take landmark
data from uh from motion capture and we
try and classify
uh what kind of action is being taken
using signatures
drone identification so
taking in data from radar and other
things to try and detect drones and
identify drones
again the all of these with asterisks's
are things that we have examples of on
our website
natural language processing
yes
sentences and paragraphs
are
our paths in some sense
and therefore we can compute their
signatures and we can use those
signatures to
classify
things about language the example we
have on our website is using
uh pap signatures to identify the author
of
works taken from the project gutenberg
corpora of
books
analyzing data usage um so i don't have
an example of this but there is a paper
which is listed on our website
where we take
energy data so voltage and current and
we use this to
understand energy usage in a house over
a very long time this was a very big
calculation
something like
five years of
energy data
and analysis of radio frequency which i
don't think is listed on our website but
is an ongoing project that we have
looking at data from uh
[Music]
radio
things
i'm not i don't remember exactly the
context
so again this is just a note for
uh people who are looking at my slides
later
so where to find out more um so this is
uh
information that can be found on our
website datasig.ac.uk
um if you go to the research section
you'll see
our recent preprints and um a list of
self-contained jupiter notebook examples
um
that you can work through and
see if you have
uh
you know any usage for these these
techniques
there's also uh our github
um
uh if you take the e-cig off you'll get
our
sort of github organization which has
all the examples mentioned above plus
some other code
um
that's all uh and then my personal
details at the bottom so you can reach
me at sam.molly at maths.ac
maps.ox.ac.uk
my personal website and my github
both in a climb bottle
thank you does anybody have any
questions
[Applause]
interesting talk
one general question is what do you
think your techniques can achieve that
other methods can't what see
the advantage of your signature methods
compared to say historical methods
so
the big advantage of signature methods
is that they
in in my eyes
besides the uh theoretical things there
there's one really big example and
that's this
size compression
and the signature is not actually the
most efficient you can actually date the
log signature which kind of throws away
the redundancy
and this is an even more compact
representation
but signature is is a tool that one
might use so
it's not like it's just a single method
that you can apply in certain scenarios
is something that you might incorporate
as well as other things to improve your
results or to
take in time series data that you
couldn't otherwise use
or to provide some extra information
about the temporal effects of time
series data um there are lots of
different things that you can do with it
that
are not mutually disjoint from other
things
cheers thanks very much
that's very interesting talk um i did
have just one kind of question about the
setup of the signatures um you mentioned
that you could have set up a truncation
to some level yes in live cases like in
real life examples is there some way to
intuitively pick that kind of level or
do you have to kind of trial and error
this or maybe you know as a form of
cross-foundation
yeah so um in the
uh applications that i've worked on
personally this has been a sort of hyper
parameter that we've tuned
um so we we would include this as our
part of our
grid search or cross-validation uh
randomized search
um so yes this is something that you
absolutely need to play with um
higher order terms are more expensive to
commute compute
so if you can get away with fewer terms
and then using lower order term lower
order signatures then that might be
beneficial if you're looking to do
something very quickly
if time is not a problem and you you've
got a lot of computer memory then using
a higher order signature might give you
better results but there will probably
be a point of diminishing returns
cheers thank you
yeah yeah so related to that question uh
i was wondering if you can give us a
more like intuition of what the
signatures mean
and uh so related to the question where
do we cut so for example if i do
something like a fourier transform and i
throw out the coefficients i know that
i'm throwing out high frequency
coefficients but here
i just don't know what i'm throwing out
right so
a fourier transform takes in
um a signal
and it takes the signal to the frequency
domain so you transform from the
frequency from the signal to the
frequency domain the signature on the
other hand is is a little bit more
complex than that
it's a description of the variability of
the path
so
[Music]
it's it's a little bit different in
terms of the
way that the
path is constructed
something that i didn't talk about is
exactly how this works theoretically
but basically
one can compute signatures in places
where fourier transforms would give you
kind of nonsense or would
it wouldn't help you so much
um because there are some assumptions
that you have to make for for fourier
transforms to be actually useful
um
having said that um
they're not terribly dissimilar because
as you say a fourier transform is really
capturing the frequency the frequencies
at which some some uh path is is varying
so
they're not totally dissimilar but
they're they're
they're definitely
very different um for example you you
can't use you can't go back easily from
a signature to a path that's that's a
difficult operation to perform
it's very easy for for a
fourier series of course
thank you
signatures are a dimensionality
reduction technique
as a dimensionality reduction technique
what
paths
would would have
the same
truncated signature but possibly
quite different appearance
okay so
um
[Music]
there are obviously paths which would
have the same truncated signature as one
another
um
so for example if you had a path
which broadly speaking varied in the
same way
in the larger sort of strokes
um then its signature would look
something very similar to a path where
the broad strokes were the same but
there was a lot of high frequency very
small
variance in the
detail
sometimes the entire signature of the
path is quite short so
for example if you take paths where
you only vary in
the
sort of rectilinear dimension uh
directions so a parallel to the axes
and you only you take one step
in each
direction at most once
then this path i believe if memory
serves is completely described by its
signature up to level three
um
these are
innovative paths i believe is what
they're called in the literature but i
couldn't cite exactly where they appear
so for example those those will be
completely described by a signature
level three but you could easily imagine
a path which looks like this in the sort
of
10 000 foot view but as soon as you zoom
in to you know
a few centimeters it looks
very fuzzy
those might have some signatures look
very similar
thank you very much for the talk um very
very simple question um
do you think that signature could be
used for partitioning uh time series
like in a clustering scenario or stuff
like that and if so would it help with
extremely large
time series absolutely
yeah absolutely um i think that
one of the applications that we've been
looking at is trying to detect anomalies
in a long sequence of events as a time
series so
we take
a very long thing and we compute
expected signatures over small intervals
and then we compare
new intervals to the expected signature
and if they look very different then we
can say that well something unusual
happened in this interval
so this is a technique that we've
absolutely done before
i'm not sure exactly of the success
or how reliable it is at the moment but
there is definitely an example of this
somewhere on our website
um thank you for the talk is it correct
to think of signature as a
pre-processing step
and then once i have the signatures i
can apply different focusing machine
learning models based on the
problem
but i'm wondering if there's there are
models that are more
that matches better to this particular
type of pre-processing
um
i i don't know of a model where the
signature would work
especially well
i know that we've used it with great
success in combination with tree based
models
lgbm specifically
so
there are certainly some models which
are
tried and tested so to speak um
but i'm not aware of any reason why you
couldn't just plug this into
anything i know that i know that people
have
you know run this through torch
neural networks
with success as well so
i wouldn't i wouldn't want to say
definitively but um
i could imagine that there are models
where this kind of isn't the right thing
to do
perhaps sorry i can't give you a more
concrete answer
is it practical to uh put priority on
more recent data and use signatures at
the same time
yeah so
you could for example take
uh signatures over rolling windows
and weight them according to how recent
they are
for example that might be something you
could do
of course it depends entirely on what
you're trying to model or
classify or you know what your global
task is but absolutely you can compute
signatures of rolling things the
signature actually
is a path itself just in a much bigger
dimension than the original path
thank you very much
[Applause]
you